après la crise sanitaire qui avait
interrompu des mois de grogne anti
gouvernementales le liban est de nouveau
confronté à un défi économique et social
coronavirus oblige la mise à l'arrêt de
l'économie a plongé un peu plus le pays
dans l'instabilité
pour redresser la situation le
gouvernement a présenté le 30 avril un
plan quinquennal sens et restructurer le
secteur bancaire réformer les finances
relancer la production et réduire la
dette publique qui s'élève désormais à
170 % du produit intérieur brut
mercredi le président michel aoun a
réuni les différents groupes
parlementaires pour leur exposer les
réformes visant à obtenir l'aide du
fonds monétaire international laquelle
est estimé à 10 milliards de dollars
la demande du fmi est un passage obligé
permettant le redressement à condition
de négocier de la meilleure manière
possible sans mise sous tutelle et de
respecter les réformes réclamées par
notre peuple
mais cet appel à l'institution monétaire
est loin de faire l'unanimité dans les
rangs de l'opposition en 2018 des
négociations avaient déjà échoué face à
l'incapacité du gouvernement hariri
imposer les réformes nécessaires dans
l'opposition certains assimilent en
recours au fmi à une mise sous tutelle
certains groupes politiques doutent
aussi de la capacité de l'actuel
gouvernement a disposé des sommes
allouées
nous ne soutiendrons ni ce plan aucun
autre avant que le gouvernement ne
montre qu'il est sérieux et trouvent des
solutions aux sources de gaspillage dans
le pays
si nous recevons par exemple un don ou
après il faut que cette somme puisse
rester au sein du gouvernement
sinon la recherche de prêts de dons ou
la négociation avec le fonds monétaire
international seront vaines explosion du
chômage dévaluation de la livre
libanaise inflation supérieure à 50% la
situation économique du liban s'est
dégradée ces dernières semaines les
conditions de vie
deviennent très difficiles pour la
population bon 50% vit au dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
une pression qui provoque de plus en
plus de manifestations émaillées de
violences dans les rues du pays
comme si finalement le confinement
n'avait fait que repousser l'échéance